hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american vampire action and comedy
movie called day shift
the movie begins with a seemingly
ordinary pool cleaner bud doing his job
in los angeles homes
however when the homeowner leaves he
reveals his hunting gear and breaks into
a nearby house
he is actually a vampire hunter who
hunts vampires for their fangs as those
can be sold at high prices he encounters
an old lady and a younger male and then
defeats them who turn out to be elder
vampires
after that he takes their fangs and
leaves using his unassuming truck
bud goes home and treats his wounds
he also pours a sticky yellow substance
all around his body he then picks up his
daughter paige from school takes her to
yogurt world and then drives her to his
ex-wife's home jocelyn
bud soon learns that jocelyn cannot
afford paige's tuition and dental costs
thus she plans to sell her house and
move with paige to florida devastated
because he would not be seeing paige
again bud promises her to find the
amount of money needed for paige so they
do not have to move
jocelyn gives him until monday next week
meanwhile a real estate agent audrey who
is also a vampire is talking to another
vampire who does not agree with her ways
and is buried alive beneath a newly
constructed house
bud goes to a pawn shop owned by his
close acquaintance troy to sell the
vampire fangs
troy only gives a fairly cheap price for
the fangs if bud wants to get more money
he suggests buds sell it to the union an
official establishment of vampire
hunters which bud was kicked out from
some time ago
however bud still gets some money from
troy by selling his gun and air jordan
sneakers
back at the car he receives a call from
paige now bud is determined to collect
the money for paige's tuition and braces
so she does not have to be apart from
him
he contacts another friend of his
nicknamed big j asking for help
meanwhile audrey discovers the death of
vampires previously killed by bud
she mourns then sniffs the house to
figure out the killer
she and her assistant deduce the killer
was just one man then they are
determined to find him
bud meets big j and together they go
into the union meeting the head of the
organization named ralph seeger
they express budd's intention to rejoin
the union and big j vouchers that bud
has changed since he was expelled from
the union due to his mistakes however
ralph is unsure of bud considering he
has violated many codes including
endangering a fellow union member's life
during a hunt due to having a rather
aggressive hunting style
after tough negotiations ralph agrees to
admit but into a one-week probation
period he would be tasked with the day
shift even though he begs to be placed
in the night shift when more money could
be made
ralph also places a union representative
that should always accompany bud during
his hunt to make sure he does not
violate any code after meeting with
ralph bud goes to the union's accounting
section to sell his fangs he is served
by seth an ordinary clerk who turns out
to be the union rep ralph assigned to a
company bud during his probation
although seth is hesitant because he
thinks he is not suitable for field
tasks ralph promises to promote him if
he can finish the job
seth comes to bud's apartment early in
the morning and sees him prepare for the
hunt
bud does not act friendly towards him
even though seth offers breakfast and
tries to be friendly
along the way bud questions seth about
his vampire knowledge even though he has
never been hunting vampires before seth
has outstanding textbook knowledge
regarding vampires and the union codes
he knows there are five types of
vampires the one that bud will be
hunting today is juveniles people who
were still young when they were turned
into vampires although their fangs do
not worth much compared to other vampire
species bud decides to keep hunting them
anyway to raise money for paige
meanwhile audrey reaches troy's pawn
shop and finds one of the old lady
vampires fangs he asks troy who gave him
the fang but troy refuses to answer
audrey tells him that vampires were once
worshipped as gods by humans
she intends to restore the old glory
back by using her day job as a realtor
to reclaim property throughout the
valley neighborhood in los angeles for
vampires to inhabit she brutally murders
troy after he still refuses to cooperate
with her back to bud's hunting he and
seth arrive at an abandoned bowling
alley a perfect hiding spot for juvenile
vampires
bud orders seth to stay in the car
despite him being instructed by seeger
to follow him at all times
seeger then calls seth urging him to
follow bud so he can verify if bud
violates any union code
entering the bowling alley he quickly
becomes anxious as he has never
experienced the horror of vampire
hunting before but bud skillfully
defeats all vampires
seth terrorized by the experience pukes
and wets his own pants
bud calms him down drives him home and
gives him the same yellow substance he
also uses
it is a special mixture to mask their
body scent so vampires would find it
difficult to track them after getting
back in his truck bud realizes seth has
left his notebook behind and reads it
he then texts jocelyn that he has raised
half of the money needed and tells her
to be patient coming home he bumps into
a new tenant next door heather
apparently a nurse
the next day bud picks seth up at his
house and reads his notebook out loud
seth has recorded all violations bud did
yesterday but has not reported them to
ralph
budd pleads with seth to give him a
couple of days enough to raise money for
paige then he can be expelled from the
union again
he goes to troy's pawn shop to buy some
equipment but finds troy's decapitated
body instead they also find bud's name
has been written on the table probably
spilled by troy after he was tortured by
audrey
seth immediately wants to report the
civilian deaths to ralph but budd
forbids it he then admits that the real
reason for his determination to rejoin
the union despite his tendency to
violate the codes is to raise money for
his daughter before he loses her
seth pities him and agrees to not report
bud's violations to ralph until monday
coming home bud sees heather arguing
with a man from her apartment's window
the next day bud and seth encountered
the nazarian brothers famous vampire
hunters disguised as stereo repairs
they agreed to work together to assault
a vampire hive and split the share
seth pees on himself again and is almost
bitten while the others skillfully
defeat the vampires after all the
vampires are defeated seth observes that
the hive consists of different species
of vampires living together which is
unusual the nazarian brothers also
discussed that vampires now invent some
kind of sunscreen that allows them to
stay out in the sun for minutes so they
can go outside during the daytime
on the way home bud praises seth's
improvement and tells him that he has
the potential to be a hunter
after his hunt bud takes paige to her
friend's birthday party while waiting
for the kids he receives a call from
audrey threatening him
he immediately knows he and his family
are in danger and quickly picks paige up
to go home
he notices audrey's men chasing after
him thus he tells paige to wear her
headphones and play games on her ipad
while he outruns the chasers
butt identifies one of the chasers as
the man he is seen arguing with heather
last night
unfortunately audrey has arrived at
jocelyn's house and takes her hostage
but also sees unconscious seth laying in
the living room after getting bitten by
the vampires audrey leaves bud taking
jocelyn and paige with her
she is certain that once seth has woken
up he will eat butt however even with
his bloodlust and newly obtained vampire
abilities seth is still no match for bud
who quickly decapitates him
surprisingly he is still alive and
attempts to reattach his head onto his
body by himself
they both leave the house and go to
heather's apartment as butt realizes she
may be working with audrey
budd and seth then learned that heather
was turned into a vampire by audrey so
she is forced to do things for audrey
even unwillingly
audrey is after bud because the old lady
bud killed earlier was her daughter and
she seeks revenge
as they speak audrey brings jocelyn and
paige to a vampire holy ground where she
plans to turn paige into a vampire and
lets her bite jocelyn
meanwhile seth is trying to navigate his
new life as a vampire and utilizes new
abilities guided by heather seth and
heather agree to help bud take down
audrey then they head to her underground
base
seth has secretly informed big j which
surprisingly shows up to help when the
three are overwhelmed by so many
vampires
at one point during the fight big j is
bitten but he refuses to give up
he lets bud go to face audrey alone
while he sacrifices himself by
detonating a bomb to eliminate the
emerging vampires
seth and heather encounter audrey's
bodyguard while bud seeks audrey after a
tough two versus one battle the
bodyguard eventually gains the upper
hand by choking seth and heather on each
of his hands but they manage to release
themselves by pulling the bodyguard's
limbs to different directions until they
break apart on the other hand even
though audrey possesses super strength
and super speed bud manages to outsmart
her by secretly setting a thin silver
rope in front of him this is indeed a
very effective method because when she
approaches him at high speed she
accidentally passes through the rope and
it cuts through her neck killing the
vampire instantly with all the vampires
defeated budd embraces jocelyn and paige
then they meet heather and seth whom bud
introduces as good vampires
ralph and his union team arrive at the
scene and scold butt and seth for not
reporting anything he begins to accuse
them of violating many codes but seth
defends themselves by exploiting
loopholes in the rules
even though he is not promoted from
clerk seth decides he will make a better
hunter working alongside bud
as bud and his family drive away big j
who survives the explosion because he is
now a vampire emerges from the manhole
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching